[Music]
all right let's reach out to Todd in
Salt Lake City what's up
Todd not much how are you we're partying
dude what's up I'm just working um okay
my question I was listening to your show
a couple months ago on the podcast and
uh I heard a couple qualities of the
jerk husband and a few of them rang the
chord with me and uh need some help
man I I almost think you you instantly
opt out of jerk well I won't say you
automatically opt out but bro that's a
big step for you to say hey that's me
and I don't want to be like this anymore
good for you man you got my you got my
mad respect on that man so uh what are
you working
through um you know I just one of the
characterists that stood out and I've
told my wife that she takes the
victimhood route sometimes and so that
definitely strung a chord just fill out
of distance between us more often than
not and it's me um I'm guarded I have my
barriers up and just can't quite figure
out why good let's uh I mean dude that's
you are at the starting line man
congratulations um how long have you
been married 18 years 18 years you got
kids four kids tell me about your
wife um
she's you know good Mom good wife she
just uh she's been primarily a
stay-at-home wife for a long time
um just kind of getting back into the
the Working World and um so she's taking
that on and how long have you how long
have you protected yourself from
her a long time dude probably like I
would say 10 years 12 years what kicked
that
off I think it came off when she like
when she found out I was watching
pornography back a long time ago and the
way she reacted to that and the lot of T
the emotional turmoil and things that
happened mhm um with that okay a lot of
Shame embarrassment you know she felt
inadequate all those things and then you
ended up with a lot of Shame and
embarrassment and you felt
inadequate and you kind of just built
your own house on either side of the of
the river there huh yeah 100%
okay um what was
um I'm from a uh I guess you call it a
new camp if you will
um where I'll call them vices for lack
of better terms just to easiest way to
describe them but things that we do um
that we know in the long term aren't
good for us they're going to kill us in
some shape form or fashion but in the
short-term work they
help and um it might sound crazy but I
classify pornography in that in that
boat it works in the very very short
term and then it kind of destroys
everything over time um what was
pornography getting you at the time cuz
here's my guess is my guess is it got
called out with that one particular
thing but my guess is the separation was
way before that even yeah you're right
probably um I would say like what did it
get me it got me like decompression
right like stress release I was going
through school at the time um pretty
newly married um a kid on the way uh so
there was a lot going on and you know
traditionally I didn't think myself as a
smart person so school's always been a
challenge for me so there's a lot of
stress and it was kind of a high stakes
program so a lot of stress and anxiety
and it's something I've been doing since
I was young to kind of deal with
emotional stuff sure I want to go
beneath the Stress and Anxiety though
because it does like you know
pornography alcohol like all that stuff
like certain drugs they they work as a
Xanax right actually Xanax works as a
Xanax right it works but you said
something underneath that that's really
important um you were in a very tough
academic program and you've never been a
smart guy insert story here uh you're a
guy who works really hard and you like
to have answers for your
friends and now you got a kid on the
way you I'm gonna I love this woman I
love my girlfriend we're going to have
this fun marriage we're going to to have
sex all the time now you're about to be
a dad and you've never been married to a
pregnant woman and I don't know how to
do this either so there's that less than
less than less than shame I should know
and I don't know and I don't know I
don't know I'm just going to go to this
one and I love how you said it stress
release because most people think they
go to it for x or for y or for Z many
many millions of people go to it as a
way to distract thems from a life they
don't
like or a life that here's a better I
don't know how to
do yeah
um so then you Foster that and you just
pour gasoline on it for 10 years or 20
years right and now you're here almost
on knock on the door two decades of
being
married and is that phrase uh you sit by
each other on the couch you're six
inches apart but 6,000 miles away from
each other a lot of times
yeah so you want to you want to make
your way back or is this is this when
you call it because a lot of people get
this far and they're like dude we had a
good run we raised good kids we we held
together a good household for the back
half of our life let's split up and
let's ride or die with somebody that's
just going to be wheels
off no no it's worth working back to
yeah for sure okay so um we don't have a
ton of time together I'd love man I'd
love to to talk to you and your wife
sometime what can I help you with today
what are you thinking about that you
want to work through that you want to
think about doing
differently uh I just I want to to work
my way back or just learn how to lower
my walls you know um get those defensive
defenses down that are primarily on my
side of the the river so to speak okay
so I think there's two things to play at
play here number one
y'all both y'all can't move into one
another's house on either side of the
river MH youall have to both leave the
house you're in and decide together
we're going to build a new one IM that
okay okay so you have to think of it
this way the marriage up until now 18
years has gotten you here we're going to
decide to build a new marriage and in
this new marriage I am going to be this
this is what I need in this in this new
marriage
season and I want you to not because I
can hear it in your voice bro you're not
broken there's nothing wrong with you
yeah okay
um your body has a very keen
understanding of what happens when you
get embarrassed in front of your
wife she nukes
you and your body knows okay
cool we hide that's where we
go and your body got a bunch of uh
cinder blocks started building some
walls and that way nobody's getting
inside the innert and it actually it
keeps the peace right yeah it also keeps
all the good stuff out
too yeah right and so the only way
through it I wish there was another way
bro the only way through it is to bite
down on your mouthpiece and head
directly through it and that's to sit
down with your wife and say
um in a in an effort to protect myself
from getting embarrassed or feeling
ashamed I walled off and I've forced you
to chase
me and live off gulps of air for the
last 20 years and I'm not doing that
anymore and I want to be fully present
with you and I want to be vulnerable I
want us to be open I want to build a new
kind of
marriage and I don't know how to do that
and by the way it's going to feel weird
as all crap to her
too she in intellectually she wants
something different she's been trying to
get it for so long but often when
somebody just starts being vulnerable
their partner melts yeah like just suck
it up I mean they start saying crazy
stuff like I've been asking for this for
20 years and I can't get it right
um give me one Behavior you want to
change gosh
um let me no let me ask you this before
before that are you what what are you
using now to relieve stress still
pornography from time to time but
getting a a handle on it CU I'm I
basically rebuilt my life in the last
two years on my you know just working on
myself doing some leadership stuff
and you know just bettering myself and I
think I'm better to be able to go back
in and help repair my marriage can I
tell you something really hard yeah this
is going to go against all the Bro
Science that we know okay if you are
married you cannot work on yourself in
isolation sure okay sir okay so good for
you man you've done a bunch of stuff but
you haven't done the hard stuff and
you're going to be like what are you
talking about I started working out I
started listening to Joo podcast I
started doing all this like I started
taking supplements um when you're
married all of your changes impact her
because y'all are one yeah right it's
like the quarterback can't just run out
and be like dude I'm not running those
plays anymore he's got to tell the team
the team has to work together to run
those two
plays yeah cuz the first few plays he
may actually fool everybody on the field
and get some good games and after a
while he's gonna get himself
killed yeah because there's nobody
blocking with know how I just didn't
know how to bring her in no I got that
yeah it's a skill set it's a skill set
and I think you sit down and
uh I recommended this on a couple of
shows ago and it sounds strange and it
sounds so dude I'm going to get so much
bloody hell for it on the internets and
I just don't
care but there's something about
literally taking a knee in front of your
wife as though you're proposing to her
and holding both of her
hands and saying I've hidden most of my
life from you for 20 years I'm not
cheating on you I don't have a big
addiction um I do struggle with
pornography
still I have been trying to get
better and but I've been trying to do it
by myself
and you and I breathe the same air we we
we are we are creating something
together and so I can't move unless you
move with
me yeah are you all in and and youall
have to figure out what that means for
y'all does that sound scary oh scares
the crap out of me man freaking out is
she gonna leave you no I think being
vulnerable like just feeling like I hate
that word but yeah being vulnerable dude
I dud I hate that word I hate it man God
I hate it I don't know what call it but
yeah that's all it is and part of me
getting over my hatred of that word is
by saying it yeah and all vulnerability
means is
this it means that I you can hurt me
with what I'm about to tell you yeah and
what I'm about to tell you is I love you
and I want you I want to be more
connected with you and I don't know how
to do
that and you're gonna
go and she's gonna say like I need you
to have all the answers no I don't know
any white that says that they're like oh
thank God right um but then it feels
weird coming back but it sounds like
that's the first place to
start and that doesn't mean that you're
not tough that doesn't mean you don't
lift weights that doesn't mean I'm doing
something with jao like in two weeks
doesn't mean you don't hang I love that
guy you don't not listen to ja that's
not what that means yeah it means that
every morning you wake up and you say
hey honey how can I love you
today I've heard you say that a lot it
makes me cringe inside why okay tell me
that because your voice is important
because there's a million men who listen
and go oh God okay whatever why does
that make you cringe I again it's a
place that makes me vulnerable right is
it is it because you're supposed to
know maybe or is it because that's not
even my freaking job I'm not going to
love her today I'm going out to kill
something and drag it home and make the
money like what is it I think it's I
think it's because I don't know how to
do it I just don't know how to do it
yeah it's yeah it's not about yeah I'm
going to go work today but um I don't
know how to do it so maybe I'm afraid of
failing on that front again you know
damn
Todd dude that's dude that's I mean
that's what I was scared of scared to
death what if my wife says here's what I
need you to love me I need you to help
with bedtime with the kids and I have to
look my wife in the eye and say I don't
know how to do that yeah or my daughter
doesn't want me to read her bedtime
stories and she will scream and kick and
tell me to get
out and I can't handle that I don't know
how to handle
that that was my
house okay yeah like I didn't know how
to do it and the like you the thing that
I love about you is like what do you do
for a living I'm a nurse yeah dude how
many times you been put in a situation
you got figure it out because that cat
on that table's about to
die and often that's who you
are but in that situation I'm GNA I'm
going to give some Insider baseball
you'll get this Todd but most people
listening who are not in the emergency
response World won't get this um they
train us early on you always have to
bring a calm presence to that kind of
situation when someone's going to die
because um you you bringing chaos and it
it just makes everything worse and they
always tell us at the end of the day
it's their emergency not yours so bring
your peace to the situation right and so
what I'm going to say is awful and I
know but it's it's it's
instructive if you give it your
all with one of your
patience and they don't make
it you're devastated and there's grief
but they're the ones who passed
away yeah in this
situation if you give it your all and
something doesn't work your wife can
look at you and say I don't I reject
that yeah you've hurt me for 20 years
you're using pornography again I'm out
I'm divorcing you just like I told you
10 years
ago yeah right all that can all happen
that's vulnerability she could kill
you but also in my house I lead with I'm
scared to say this out loud my wife says
I hear
that I think that's a good way to start
yeah and I think that's how she'll
respond so she will she will hey I'm I I
can't tell you how proud of you I am oh
thank you what you're embarking on is
really really hard it's a
challenge hang on the line here I'm
going to give you a copy of building a
non-anxious life and um I'll go ahead
and and drop in the thing I'll go ahead
and drop in own your past change your
future building an un- anxious life I
think is going to give you in your wife
a road map an architectural blueprint to
build this new house together and here's
what I think is going to be important
you're a nurse you run hard you save
lives and you're a father and you're a
husband you got all of this stuff that's
pent up and it builds and it builds and
it builds and it builds and you don't
have an offramp for it and what that
means is you've built a very anxious
world then pornography alcohol texting
that woman back at work whatever the
thing is that gives you that release
that ah
that's what kills you and so if you
build something from the inside out from
the floor up that is non-anxious in in
its structure then you can go in and do
crazy hard jobs like being a nurse like
being a fireman like being a military
person like being a police officer like
being a teacher like being an attorney
like being any number of professions
business
owner you can go do really hard things
and Fight Hard bite down on your
mouthpiece and punch and kick hard but
your body never
over does
it doesn't go into anxiousness or Panic
proud of you my brother you're on your
way you're on your way you're asking
great hard
questions take a knee take both your
wife's hands and say I love you I'm
ready to build something new are you in
and then hold on tight because she may
just blow your
mind